- So I'm really delighted to
introduce this event today.
It's part of a kind of
subseries that we have going on
at the Council of Southeast
Asian Studies here at Yale.
I'm the chair of the Council
of Southeast Asian Studies.
And we have a graduate student conference
that's going on at the end of the semester
on the theme of waters.
And it's organized by
a group of inter-Asia
graduate students.
And so Al Lim, who is here, and I
got talking about the idea of water,
in Southeast Asia in particular.
So we decided that we
would have a side current,
so to speak, leading up to that
graduate student conference.
Al, if you don't mind finding
the URL to the conference,
you might put it in the chat.
I forgot to dig it up before now.
But that will be taking place
at the end of the semester.
And so then, we have these evening events,
which are in addition to our
council Brown Bag series.
But these events are all circulating
on this theme of waters.
So I'm delighted today to
present or to introduce
my friend and colleague, Andrew Johnson,
who will be talking about his
new book, Mekong Dreaming.
And rather than give an
extended introduction,
Andrew has taught at Yale
and US, at Princeton.
I've known Andrew since
graduate studies at Cornell.
I think his PhD's from around 2010.
But rather than the standard introduction,
I wanna just read a single
sentence from this book
to give you a sense of it.
You're gonna hear more about
the full topic of the book.
But I just wanna set the
tone for this evening
with this sentence:
"How to think about such moments,
when a glimpse into a higher
plane reveals a garbled,
incomprehensible message."
Let me just read that
sentence one more time.
"How to think about such moments
when a glimpse into a higher plane
reveals a garbled,
incomprehensible message."
It's a really profound passage in a book
that's full of profound and
very interesting reflections
on the art of field work,
about the encounters with the
supernatural, the uncanny,
the inexplicable, and a
meditation along the banks
of the Mekong, which is
really quite a fascinating way
to get us into our discussions
about waters in Southeast Asia.
And to take us, last week we had a talk
in the Brown Bag series by
Jim Scott about the Irrawaddy.
And so, now we've moved to
another important deltaic system
in a important river in Southeast Asia.
But here, I think what's
fascinating is we're taking it
from the realm of the
material, and the social,
to the realm of the uncanny,
and how those intersect
with the material and the social.
So I won't say any more,
but I wanna turn it over
to my friend and colleague Andrew Johnson,
to take us on a little journey
with today's proceeding.
So, I'm gonna mute myself
and turn it over to Andrew,
and he'll have a talk
for standard talk length
discussion of the book.
And then, after that we'll have time
for question and answer period,
and I'll moderate that
when we get to that.
So, thank you Andrew, and welcome.
- Thanks.
Thanks so much, Al, and thanks
Erik, for that introduction.
And thanks for inviting me here.
It's a pleasure to be speaking
to (indistinct) at Yale.
And I'm really thrilled to be here.
I'd also like to
introduce a friend of mine
(indistinct) who is there
at the banks of the Mekong,
and he's gonna show some
video of the river where
what I'm gonna be talking
about, and some of the ...
So you can kind of see in real time
what's going on there as I talk about it.
(Speaking in a foreign language).
Okay, so without further ado, I'll start.
This year, the Mekong river changed color.
Its flow was normally a muddy
brown, red and local parlance.
But this year, as last year,
the flow turned a beautiful blue,
it's deep silty water became clear,
and those living out of it's banks,
could see further down
than they could remember.
But no one understood
the change in the rivers
quality is a good thing.
Fishermen could see now
fish rotting on the bottom,
and nets that normally
hung in slow moving eddies,
and the flow became clogged with algae,
(speaks in foreign language).
This green mass could be sometimes
be pounded and roasted into a sort of
a Laotian version of Nori.
But whenever advantage this
newly abundant food source had
was offset by this damage to fishing gear,
nets and boat propellers
became clogged and useless,
as thick green mats float
through the river and choked
off the flow.
Further, even for unclogged nets,
this clear water presented
another kind of a problem.
The kinds of nets the fishermen used,
these thin filaments of blue polyester,
rely on being invisible to
fish in red silty water,
hence the name (indistinct),a
trick of the eye.
These tricks however,
don't work in clear flow.
In recent years, all in
the Mekong are dealing
with a radically different
river, with different water,
a different biota, and
different techniques,
that one might use to deal with it.
But this is not limited
to the area that I'm gonna
be talking about today,
the middle Mekong in between
Thailand and Laos elsewhere.
One of the most significant
hydrological events
in the world simply failed to manifest.
As the annual backflow
of the Mekong ceased.
Now, normally what would happen,
is as the monsoons flow into the river,
the river turns back on itself
flowing upstream into
the (indistinct) lake,
and filling the lake in
the middle of Cambodia,
which provides most of the
protein and food resources
for that country.
But this year it didn't.
For a fisherman this is
exceptionally troubling.
The Mekong provides most of
the protein for Cambodia,
and it's the heart of
Laos and of the Isan,
the Laos speaking region in Thailand.
And fisheries have
crashed in recent years,
and with them entire ways of life.
The reasons for all of
these changes have to do
with a complicated mixture
of hydrology and geopolitics.
We could think about it in this way,
if you want it to.
We could think about national priorities,
or economic agendas.
We could think about the
Mekong river commission,
as sort of multi body
international organization
of Mekong States, that
seeks to manage and profit
from the rivers flow.
We can think about it in
terms of national developments
of natural resources shared
between Thailand and Laos.
But resources that belong
to this or to that nation.
We could think about it as a
potential political flashpoint
between China and Isan.
But, that's not really what I do.
I'm an anthropologist, and
that means I sort of zoom in
to ask what these changes mean,
in the lives of ordinary people?
And what I wanna argue here,
is that the crisis in the river
affects people on
multiple different levels.
It's a crisis of ecology,
of hydrology, of economy,
of family, of imagination, of religion.
So, here if one weakness
that I think a lot of work
on water and hydrology has,
is that it gets really open to metaphors.
And so the metaphor I'm gonna use,
is not quite flows, and not
quite streams of consciousness
as this is entitled but a net.
So relations are revealed
to be interlinked.
And a mirror of the
blue (indistinct) nets,
new ecological, social and
spiritual realms are interwoven.
It's a core contention here
that meaningful distinctions
between the ecological, the
economic, the spiritual,
the social, are not really so evident.
You might use the term ontological.
Other people have used
the term ontological
to refer to a realm that
encompasses all that exists
within the world, but there's an important
caveat to that idea.
While all the ontological
configurations are in flux.
There's no point at which
there's a harmonious status.
There's one ontology that one could equate
with a kind of a culture or tradition.
Something that lasts unchanged over time.
Such configurations are always changing.
In a moment of ecological collapse,
relations are even more in flux,
with catastrophic
effects and all involved.
Further just as we have a net,
that its strands extend out
into the Mekong's murky flow.
The strands that make up
a net often lead beyond
the zones of apprehension.
A bit like that passage that
Erik read from the book.
We don't quite know where
these strands lead yet.
But still we hope to follow them,
and to harness their potential.
Tim Ingold has talked
about these relations
as a politics of dwelling.
It's a way to rethink a binary between
a static agentive people and
a reactive passive nature.
And to kind of break apart
the assumption of fact
that the idea of nature has.
Nature in contrast, is
not the raw conditions
out there to be perceived,
apprehended and utilized
by an agentive person.
But which we change, and we are changed by
this physical being with
the material and biota
with which we interact.
Such a process of dwelling
creates what Ingold calls
a sense of place.
But here today, something has gone awry.
As outside forces collapsed
inward upon the Mekong,
and most significantly
of which hydro-power,
and most significantly,
which Chinese hydro-power
which we'll talk about in a moment.
This politics of dwelling
becomes more fraught.
Especially in recent years,
hydro-power projects,
the expansion of highly
destructive forms of fishing,
fishing with bombs, fishing
with agricultural pesticides,
or fishing with electricity,
rapid economic and ecological change,
and an alteration of the
local spirits of place,
that forever change this
notion of a sense of place
as we have in Ingold, and who's drawing,
of course from Heidegger.
As I argue here, it's not
an collapse that destroys
placemaking entirely, but
one which weaves into it
threads obfuscation and
uncertainty, anxiety, the cult.
So to zoom out for a moment,
just to situate everybody
and make sure that we're all talking
about the same river here.
The Mekong is one of the largest
in the world by drainage.
It's the kind of the
aorta of Southeast Asia.
It flows down from the Tibetan plateau.
Through two series of
turbulent Rapids through China.
Then down forms the border
between Laos and Burma.
Then between Thailand and Laos.
Eventually it goes into
the heart of Cambodia,
and flows out South of Saigon in Vietnam.
It's a river split, by
political boundaries
and carries with it a legacy of political
conflicts and wars.
But what you're seeing today ...
Can everybody see the video here?
Is that ...
Can we put ...
It would be nice (indistinct) video on?
Oh, yeah, okay.
So this part ...
(speaks foreign language)
What you're seeing today, the
river begins to flatten out
after its turbulent beginnings.
Stretches are still marked
by Rapids and waterfalls,
but other regions become broad.
Sometimes this is just a
result of the time of year.
During the monsoon, the water
level can jump up nine meters
turning what looks like a scrub forest
into a broad expanse of water,
and then back down to a
trickle during the dry season.
Large-scale alteration to the
river has come slowly, right?
At least in comparison with
many other river systems
in the world.
The Mekong region was not
high priority for China,
being far from the centers.
So power in the middle of Mekong area,
has been war torn for hundreds of years.
Well, American audiences might
think of the Vietnam war,
the Khymer Rouge, and
these kinds of things,
even in the 17 and 1800s,
cities such as the Vientiane
were sacked and burned in wars
from between Siam and Laos.
But change has come, and
it's come very rapidly now.
Beijing has resolved to do
something about barriers to trade
between China and areas
further downstream,
and as a result they've been
blasting Rapids in the river,
trying to make the flow
navigable by cargo ship.
These alterations are happening upstream
of where (indistinct) is right now.
Which itself is a little
bit upstream from Vientiane,
but the changes in the
river are keenly felt.
Specifically, this has
to do with hydro-power.
The numbers of dams across
the mainstream of the Mekong,
increases every year.
Chinese and Lao advocates argue,
that these dams are necessary
to produce clean power
to fuel national developments.
Although the real
beneficiaries are likely to
be those businesses involved
in exporting the power.
There are 11 now in China,
across the main stream
of the river, before it even
flows into Southeast Asia,
and especially the Nuozhadu Dam,
has profound impacts on water downstream.
Effectively in 2019, completely stopping
the pulse of the Mekong.
At other times, the dams release water,
and leading to unexpected gouts of water
that rushed downstream causing
chaos to those living below.
So, in the wake of one
of these floods in 2015,
I followed one fishermen who
I'm gonna call Bong here.
He and I went down the river looking
for what are the nets
that had been swept away
in the flood before.
And as he guided us
through the maze of rocks,
and islands washed clean
of by the recent flood,
we moved through clumps of
bushes with branches there,
except for a very thin
line of foliage marking
the highest extent of the recent water.
These are shrubs that would
ordinarily be submerged
during the wet season, then
exposed during the dry season,
leaf bear fruit and to be submerged again,
where the fish could come eat the fruits,
and then distribute the
seeds and things like this.
But a rise fall of the river
in the space of a week,
as opposed to a year,
it gives very little
time for such processes.
The buds are smothered,
before they even have a chance to grow,
and fruit never appears.
So, as Bong steered me through
a series of narrow channels,
he related to me the multiple
different fishing techniques,
that he used to use just a few years ago
that no longer worked to catch catfish.
The use of road kill dog
flesh, pickled in urine ,
to catch the giant catfishes,
slightly smaller carnivorous cousin,
the use of a drop of opium on large hooks,
for certain kinds of large fish.
Certain incantations and
spells, Buddhist chants,
that could coax a catfish to the net,
a petition to the Naga,
kind of a large water dragon
that I'll talk about a
little bit more today,
to guide fish towards him.
A specific request to
the Lord of the Fish,
a spirit that ruled over and managed
the local giant catfish.
The cat is one of his subjects.
Finding a patch of very silty red water,
in which nets could be hung,
invisible to passing fish.
Points to a failure of technique
across multiple levels.
Its own technologies for
catching fish, no longer work.
And these are technologies
that are not just material.
We're not just talking about
bait, and nets, and hooks,
and traps and other kinds of things here.
But this is also a reading of the water,
knowing where to put the nets,
having the right kind of
interpersonal relations with Nagas,
with the Lord of the Fish,
with other powers on the river
to hang his nets.
Each of these for Bong,
are both part of the
same process of dwelling.
Each of these are interlinked,
and each of these failed.
So in my book, here.
By the way, the islands,
this island here that you can see,
the tree is no longer there,
but it's the one right
behind (indistinct).
(speaking in foreign language)
Anyway, you can see how the
island has changed itself
over the years.
In the book, I look at the
sense of loss and trace links
between hydro-power and
what we might call dwelling
on the Mekong.
Chanting the multiple
factors that influence
how one lives with the change river.
As I mentioned, Bong's fishing involves
some knowing what particular
fish would be active,
what material bait would
draw the fish to him,
what tracks to set for the fish,
but also accessing some
further means to ensure
that the fish actually comes.
Something from (indistinct)
what we might call
magical or religious,
and which I'm just gonna call potential.
We can think of it continuing
at this metaphor of the net,
as using those lines that are partially,
or wholly obscured within the water,
and that which we need new
techniques to perceive.
Indeed while on described
techniques that no longer work,
he also described new ones that did.
The recently arrived medium of a Naga.
One who conducted spirit medium
and a very different style
from the traditional Laotian style,
spirit mediums along the river.
But rather dress in a central Thai style,
wore all the old white of anesthetic wore
heavy wooden prayer beads.
Indeed, this medium had
answered his requests one year,
and sent them two giant catfish,
just the day before he
was supposed to entertain
high ranking guests.
So in the book, I look
at the material qualities
the Mekong land and waterscape
including its temporality,
the water itself, fish,
and the changing techniques
used to access them.
And I go over these briefly today.
In the book, I go into more detail,
if you're interested in other things,
I go into more detail about
migrant labor borders,
the productive potential
for foreign actors
including spirits to
play into this change.
This in turn evolves
Mekong concepts of time,
as time and space become
vital to help potential fish
become actual fish.
And ultimately speaks towards
dwelling, in uncertain times.
The Mekong itself is in constant
motion in three directions.
It's flow is hypnotic.
It normally flows from West
East until the monsoons
and (indistinct), and of
course, down in Cambodia,
then it switches back to flow East West.
It flows up and down to
whirlpools the size of a fist form
and the surface with great sucking sounds,
travel a few meters
downstream and then dissipate.
Plateaus of water bubble
up from underneath.
These are expected when the
water flows over at great rock.
But many are unpredictable.
They form seemingly out of nowhere,
and disappear into the swirl.
There's an endless work
churn in the red brown flow.
For fishermen,
the water is a constant
topic of conversation.
It can be little lie or much lie.
It runs either red with
sediments or clear,
meaning with the
visibility of a few inches.
Now clear has come to take
a whole different meaning.
At nights of the full moon,
those living on its banks
report fireballs erupting from its steps,
at which they attribute to Naga
is living within the river.
The topography of the river
is mediated by its Rapid.
Those rocks over under and
around which the water flows,
one navigates by reference
to this or that Rapid gang,
which have names or stories.
Some like the great gang
(indistinct) have personalities,
and this latter rock
despite its reputation,
which the name means plural Rapid,
guard some of the best
fishing in the area.
A decade ago, the rapid
tour the bottom out of
a Chinese cargo vessel
attempting to go over it,
and cargo and oil floated
down the stream for days.
Sometimes, a rock is more than ...
Sometimes a gang, a rapid
is more than just a rock.
A pocket of sand might grow into a beach,
where the water drops.
Sometimes larger plants might colonize it,
and create an Island.
And around an Island, it
might make a long, lazy swirl,
a place that's really good
for fishing with a throw net,
or a place to fence
off a part of the river
to store live fish.
In my field site too, there's
a deep pool called Nong,
which is usually a word that's
used for freshwater inland.
Sorry, a place away from the river,
kind of a spring-fed pool.
Here's where the water
persists in the dry season.
When the rest of the river
drops down to a trickle,
or where the water
remains relatively still
in the wet season, when
the gang are raging.
Here too, it's where the
Mekong giant catfish live.
This is a fish I can get up
to several hundred kilograms,
about the size of a small cow.
And from where the divine King,
the Lord of the Fish rules,
a shrine to the Lord stood sands just next
to the village center,
above the swirling pool.
The village traces its roots to the pool,
from a Laotian group from
the former Royal capital
of (indistinct).
They at some unspecified point in time
in the past centuries, traveled
down to the Mekong river
until they came here,
and gazing down into the
still clear water, they
could see the forms
of giant catfish swimming in the water,
and decided that this
place was dwelling of the
Lord of the Fish.
And the 1930s, this village entertained
the Lord of (indistinct) each year,
who resided over the festivals,
calling in the Lord of the Fish to possess
the body of a medium and declared that,
catches of catfish would
be plentiful that year,
so long as everybody's
morality had been upstanding.
So, the pool which had
formerly be an off limit,
sewing to it sacred status,
is now a fishing site in recent years,
since the fishing has cratered out,
and that's still hanging
on the water today.
My point over going these
different words and description
of the river itself, means
is that in the topography
of the river makes it a
nest of distinct places.
These are places that change
depending on the time of year,
and how's a variety of
other than human beings,
and human activities,
these create a social map,
marking off space, space that varies
with the level of the water.
But the division of the
river, it's a distinct places.
Also delineates a political
system, a property ownership.
Revealing a legal grid, that
overlays hydrological grid,
and the ecological grid of the river.
According to a mutual agreement
a village had either side of the river.
Certain places are designated
as public or private,
determining who has the
right to fish where.
These locations are also, if
they serve a particular feature
there's this Eddie or that
Rapid or something like this.
The richest fishermen,
might own the rights
to fish at several sites.
And fishing plots can be
bought, sold, inherited, leased,
just like land property could too.
A good fishing site could go
for several tens thousands
back before the dams came in,
about 300 to 1000 dollars.
And if you didn't have one,
you could still throw a fish
with a throw net in a public entity,
or you could stand on
the edge of a boulder,
and try your luck with
a precarious dip net.
So, my point here, it's to
say fishing in the river
is bounded within a net of relations
that cross international borders.
In excess and outside of
legal right to a particular
zones in the river.
And it's tied in with this
hydrological features.
There's public zones with
the particular rules,
private plots with their
own system of tenure,
and until recently sacred
spots with their own particular
spirits associated with them.
But, these fishing sites,
are in the middle of an
international boundary.
Lao fishermen claim the
Mekong up to the point,
right to the Thai shore.
And suggested that they're
simply being generous neighbors
in allowing Thai national,
such as Bong upon its waters,
and allowing the system
of Lomong to persist,
but this is ignored by all involved.
Bong and others crossed this
line regularly on their boats
without any kind of paperwork.
When I press Bong, on the
competing legal definitions
of what constitutes Lao
or Thai places, the water,
he simply responded, "(indistinct)."
The nations aren't applicable here.
So the hydrology, the river,
enables claims to plots of water,
that are recognized by no authority,
higher than the village had
meant in his Lao neighbor.
These two authorities agree
on who owns what fishing site
at what time, and are
responsible for adjudicating
disputes over them.
Here too, the police
certainly cannot get involved.
A Thai police spend, it
would have questionable
authority of our property rights
claimed by another country,
not to mention midstream
and the sort of gray zone.
However, I explore in the book,
such conflicts do indeed erupt,
with Laotian police, Thai
military, Thai police,
and village heads each
pooling in their own different
separate directions.
So these systems of property
ownership and fishing rights
constitute another way of
seeing ownership and authority
in the river tied to place.
A way of seeing the river as shared space,
that has nothing to do
with Bangkok or Vientiane,
and much less to do with Beijing,
and cross river authority
as ruled more by force of
personality than legal mandate.
But with changes in the
water, become multiple changes
at the level of authority as well.
Rapids if not blasted, can
become submerged at a flood
or turn into full-fledged
islands in an ebb.
And the fisheries, these
fisheries have been some
of the hardest hit by
recent hydro-power projects.
When floods ripped through the village,
the most common casualty
are those net strung
within the fishing grounds.
The nets already become prone to tangling
to become a pale blue mess as
they're torn from the eddies
in which they float.
Most often, they end up in the morning
after the flood stranded
on top of a Boulder,
with fish too ensnared to be
removed rotting in the sun.
And of these, most are
swept away in too damaged
to be recovered.
This is the most of the
financial damage from a flood.
That's of the sites
Bong pointed out to me.
Many if not most were devoid of nets.
Here even nets have been swept away,
or equally as often bone
described the owners as waiting,
before they attempted anymore fishing.
Some had lost nets, and
were waiting for the money
to replace them, and put them back in.
Others were waiting for
the algae bloom to subside,
but some were simply
waiting for the instability
and the river to be over.
Prices for fishing plus
in the entire system
of mutual ownership went into freefall.
And recrimination, sometimes
village against village
since Lao against Thai,
and sometimes simply into personal flare
to even turning violent.
Some, abandoning net fishing altogether,
turn towards fishing with
electric charges or bums,
and the Thai police inspector
at the docks in turn
began patrolling Laotian waters
armed, and drunk at times,
firing at those he thought were fishing
using these destructive techniques.
Fishing, and by the
extension the realm managed
by local authority is changing.
The new landscape of
potential is uncertain,
and only after this new world emerges,
can decisions be made.
So, I've talked a little bit about ...
I'm gonna move forward just a little bit.
I talked a little bit about
the change and the pulse,
and the yearly pulse of the river.
And what I wanna focus on,
is how this pulse marks time.
And in that, as people
decide when to lay the nets,
and when to use what
particular techniques,
they do so based upon a
series of Buddhists festivals,
which are then linked to the
waters flood and its retreat.
This also involves planting
crops along the riverbank
as the water dies down, it
leaves a thick silty deposit
which is really good for planting
particular kinds of crop.
Now where the water rises and falls,
against natural cycles, this
becomes a possible to protect.
So, the new Mekong has a
different time from the old one.
And with it, what was once
efficacious is no longer.
If we were to reframe this
statement and theoretical terms,
the Mekong becoming dammed,
opens onto a new uncertain
field of potentiality.
And these rhythms of course,
originate when the Chinese
controlling the dam
decides to retain or release water,
decisions that are on principle
not communicated downstream.
Without the ability to
communicate with the Chinese then,
fishermen can only watch the water level
for indication that the
dam controller has acted.
They know very well,
the cause of the floods,
but not whether or not one
is coming, and when it will.
These are also changes to
popular Buddhist practice.
During the height of the dry season,
normally sandy islands
rise up out of the water
as the waterfalls.
And all these islands,
village from the Lao side and
the Thai side come together,
and make the kind of a festival village
where you can raise
tractors, and drink beer,
and engage in all the profits
that low water fishing has.
But in 2015, a glut of water came through
and wiped out the village,
causing tens of thousands of dollars
worth of damage, and entirely
disrupting the whole cycle
of the whole process of
celebrations for the boosts near.
So, patterns of rise and fall,
are one stranded in the way
that one marks its time,
and then they call them.
A yearly cyclical calendar
punctuated by Buddhist holidays,
fishing and farming
practices, the monsoon.
That dry season when you
build festival villages,
and Sandy islands emerged
from that flow coincides
with an abundance of fish,
and large fish are easy
to catch a low water.
These in turn fuel, temple donations,
sacrifices to river
beings, and social events,
and ritual activity centered
upon mobilizing villages
own potency.
And around this time, if
anybody of you have been
to Isan, I know, there's a
rocket festival where large,
very phallic rockets are
fired up into the sky,
triggering the monsoon.
So, in this way rituals kind of gain
the power to yield rain.
When the waters is near
its height and converse,
other beings to turn act.
This is the time when
people see Naga fireballs.
As Nagas come up, and spit
their own fire into the sky,
then causing the clouds to
disperse, and the water to drop.
So, land beings act to break
about the rise of the water,
river beings act to bring about its ebb.
The water, that based calendar
that the Mekong mobilizes
the potency of particular technologies.
So, the dam then alters
time, along the Mekong.
Monsoon time and Buddhist
time become disrupted
via new modes of time when the
gates open, when they shut.
And the wake of the dam, the
river, and those within it
become disentangled from the rhythms.
The Mekong water levels no
longer linked to the rain,
which in turn is delinked
to the ritual activity
meant to provoke rain.
Fish follow suit, and as the
Naga show, so do river beings.
So now in the wake of the new Mekong,
the situated knowledge fails
and new practices arise.
Moratoriums on fishing
in particular seasons,
and in particular sites have elapsed,
and response to falling yield fishermen,
to compensate for the lack of knowledge,
how to handle this new river,
turn towards other fishing techniques.
As fishermen who no longer trap
fish with old mesh methods,
and as Naga fireballs
will they still appear,
do to not bring about a
lowering of the water.
And as high water comes with,
or without Felic rockets,
river time is becomes disentangled.
Disentangled from Buddhist
time, monsoon time,
calendar time.
Events that will previously simultaneous,
are not any longer.
So now it was a different
time in which to dwell,
for people, for fish
and for spirits as well.
So as the story of the Lord
of the Fish, and the Naga,
indicate the disappearance of fish,
it's not just about economy,
rather presents a fundamental
religious problem as well.
Sources of invisible
potential on the river
are not what they once were.
Shrines to the Naga thought
to exist within the water,
were at times declared to
be shrines to dead Naga,
where the spirits lived on,
even after the physical
great serpents died,
owing to the rivers change.
As one fisherman told me
Nagas used to come out
of the river, they would come into town,
put on human clothing,
and come to the temple,
to listen to the Buddhist chanting.
Sometimes they would even
marry women from the village,
and then they stopped.
That's why I asked them to
press them a little bit further.
Well, why did they stop?
And he responded by simply,
"They got tired of us."
Elsewhere other river beings,
underwent similar transformation.
A Lao style medium, a very
similar religious professional
who featured in the right
surrounding, the giant catfish
a hundred years ago, was
the voice of an island King.
A spirit that looked after the village,
and set catches a fish to villagers nets.
But found himself openly mocked,
after a 2015 possession ritual,
where as a new male Bangkok style medium
who lived and set his life in a cave,
behind the temple gained adherence.
Old orders based around
river and fish slip away,
so replacement of the
representative of a new order,
and a new flow.
Significantly here,
the flows of international migrant labor,
the struggle to get a good work contract,
and to flow kind of
outwards from the village.
It's the removal of religious figures
from the physical realm,
including the realm of kinship,
and participation in
communal religious activity
also suggests a shift in
notions of materiality.
The physical Naga, becomes a ghostly one.
But it goes to the points
not to the uncanny,
and not to haunting, but to
the presence of new promises,
a new possibilities, even as
another way of being declines.
It's a shift that occurs
as the workings of new
liberal capitalism multiply,
as rubber prices rise and fall,
as migrant labor becomes more tenuous,
and as the political
future of the Northeast
becomes more in depth.
But more than this, the natural
world itself has changed.
As the formerly predictable Mekong,
full of beings with which one
had a particular relationship,
becomes a new kind of a place.
But, even as all that is
solid seems to melt into air,
it does not disappear,
As established economic and
environmental orders fail,
and new miraculous or
catastrophic horizons
of possibility open up, new
cosmological worlds are born.
So, through a micro examination
of the impacts of Chinese,
hydro-power on one
small fishing community.
I wanna show the scale of such changes.
The collapse of the Mekong
under new hydro-power projects,
creates alterations
that can escape notice,
if we only think about
the Mekong as a confluence
of national interests, Bangkok,
Beijing, and Vientiane,
might very well benefit
from the alterations
taking place in the river.
Thailand versus national interest
and the capital in Bangkok,
not necessarily in Isan
and Mekong regions.
And Laos has is one of
its national priorities
to become the battery of Asia.
But for many that I discuss here,
such changes involve multiple scales,
including highly personal ones.
The hydrology, the river
changes its color, its movement,
even the way one Mark
space on the river change,
this is a very intimate alteration.
Ways of marking both space and time,
ways of dividing territory,
dividing time or loss,
ways of relating to other
inhabitants of the river,
fish and spirits disappeared,
were to be replaced by
instead described further
elsewhere, new hybrids,
new spirits, new sources of
power, new sources of potential,
ones that are more uncertain,
and than ones that are more upfront.
In short, as infrastructure itself alters
the way the world works, new
sources of potential prosperous
as well as disastrous become revealed.
That's all I have for my talk right now.
I would like ...
If I could ask, like to show
a little bit more of the river
as it is.
(speaking in foreign language)
So if you can all see, this
is the stretch of river
that I'm talking about there.
You've got areas of the
bank that had been fortified
by concrete.
Over there is an island that I feature
on the cover of the book,
but that tree is now gone.
Anyway, that's looking across the border
into Laos right there.
Can people see now?
- [Erik] There was just
a shock where you see
the same sun rising over there,
but at a different time of day.
- [Andrew] Oh yeah, this is
probably at about 5:00 am
or something like that.
I think right now this is now about 9:00.
So with that, be happy to take questions,
or start discussion or ...
- Great, thank you to Andrew.
So I just wanna take a moment
and give him some applause
for a wonderful talk.
So, thank you.
Now we're gonna shift to the
question and answer period,
and I will feel the questions.
So if you have a question,
you can either use the
hand raise function on Zoom
if you know how to use that,
if not, you can send a note to the chat,
to say that you have a question,
or even put it in there,
or raise your hand wildly,
and I'll try and catch you in the video
or something like that.
I see that Paul Sarno
has the first question,
so go ahead, Paul.
- Thank you for that wonderful talk.
I think you said that there
were 11 dams in China,
that affect Mekong.
All the dams in Laos,
that affect the Mekong?
And how-
- Absolutely.
This number is constantly changing.
And so, in terms of dams
across the main stream,
(indistinct), there's one
not too far upstream here,
that's a bit a massive hydro-power project
that extends just across the
main stream of the river.
Now it's not a very deep dam,
it's not a high reservoir Dam.
So the changes that it
genders, it's not flood,
massive drying, a massive flood.
However, this clarity of the water,
the algae bloom and the
clarity of the water
that is sort of taking
the silt out of the water
occurred after the (indistinct) was built.
So it still holds back
a good deal of water,
and it's really responsible
for a lot of the changes
in the quality of the water.
However, during my field work,
the Chinese dams being
a higher reservoir dams,
have a different kind of an impact,
so there's multiple different ones.
Now elsewhere in Laos,
there's other proposed dams,
including one just, 20 minutes drive away
from this spot right here, quite close by,
and there's a vast number
of dams on tributaries
that come in, including one
just by (indistinct) as well.
There's a quick question.
Are the rocks in the
background natural or manmade?
I think you can see one
area where the village
has decided to shore up the
banks with concrete rocks.
That was a response to the dams, in fact.
Because this irregular flow,
was not allowing the stilt to
fortify the banks themselves.
You didn't get a nice kind
of sandy slope on the side
of the river, and instead
you had a constant flow
that ate away at the bank,
and you had a lot of collapse.
So what the village
government did is they came,
and they fortified it with those rocks
that you see right there.
I think that's the extent of them.
They stop up there, and then they go back
to the the village center,
and a little ways down.
Just beyond that, if you
can see in the distance,
there wouldn't be any rocks like that.
Now there are big boulders,
elsewhere that I don't think
are in frame here, which are natural.
But those particular
ones, that we've guarded
by a wire mesh are manmade.
You're welcome.
- Sorry, I muted myself.
Thank you for that question,
and for the great reply, Andrew
We have a question from Thuy Do.
Thuy do you want to ask your question now?
- Yes.
I'm not from Lao, I'm from Vietnam.
But I live in in the
Mekong Delta in Vietnam
for like seven years.
And I work closely with the farmers.
So I see, like during the flood season,
(speaks foreign language).
I don't know how ...
(indistinct).
So during the flood seasons,
the day of (indistinct)
like (indistinct) water,
it looked beautiful.
And I am not from there originally,
I'm from Southeast of Vietnam.
So when I went there, lived
there, and I see it's beautiful.
But then now they build the dyke,
the anti-flood dyke.
Professor James Scott
(indistinct) he said,
"it's the engineer (indistinct) something,
they build that dam to anti-flood."
And it change the flow of the rivers.
So it damage, it actually
damages like the farms,
the rice farms.
In the Mekong Delta in Vietnam,
we at the end of the Mekong,
so the influence of the
Mekong is significant.
Like when the Chinese, they build a dam,
so the (indistinct) not
going down to the Mekong
in the Delta in Vietnam anymore.
But and also, so now, no I'm
not talking about fishing,
because we cannot do anything with that,
so now we raise fish a lot.
We don't have natural fish from the river.
But I'm not sure in Lao,
like we now we talk about
how to prevent the influence
of the dam (indistinct)
to the rice farm.
Like the new Isan upper
river it's actually,
like during the flood season,
it bring nutrition to the
farms, now it's not anymore.
So is it the same influence in Lao?
And (indistinct), like you see anything?
And then what the Laos
government doing with that?
We do a lot, but it's not
actually (indistinct).
- There's a lot to that question.
And I think, yes, it's the
same process, absolutely.
Because the silt that gets ...
When the river comes in, and it floods,
and it carries with it all the silt,
if that gets trapped behind a dam ...
I mean, first off, if you
trap all the silt behind a dam
it decreases the efficiency
of the dam, right?
Because it clogs everything up,
and eventually over a
short period of time,
the dam stops producing
power in the way that it did
when you first built it.
So, you trap all that silt back there,
but so that's one reason
why the silt doesn't
get carried downstream, doesn't
get deposited in the Delta,
and doesn't create
fertilizer for rice farms.
Also with less flow, in
Vietnam the problem is,
you have less flow, so
saltwater creeps in,
and so you get a problem, salt
getting into rice fields too,
which is a tremendous issue.
And that also has economic effects too.
And that (indistinct) farms
get more and more common,
and more and more profitable, which are,
require a lot more equipments,
and are owned by wealthier people,
and so you get a class
economic problem there too.
But in terms of what's
going on Lao certainly,
the lack of stilts.
And then efforts like
those rocks that you saw,
that protects the banks from collapsing,
but it also speeds the water on its way,
and blasting Rapids as China
has done further upstream,
also speeds the water on us way too.
So with you faster moving
water, with less silt in it,
the water then picks up less silk,
because it's not really
able to deposit that,
and so any silt that it has,
gets jetted out into the sea,
and doesn't really get deposited.
So it's an entire change
in the way the river goes,
and Vietnam being at the
very end of the system,
gets a lot of the effects, a
lot of the downstream effects.
I see a question from
Carolyn and from Pat,
that I'd like to ask.
(speaking foreign language)
- (speaking in foreign language).
- (speaking in foreign language)
- (Speaking in foreign language)
- And so-
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Okay.
So, towards the end-
- Yeah.
- Okay, so towards the end of the year,
there is ...
As (indistinct) asked
about it's a (indistinct)
so the end of the year,
they do have competitions
as snake boat racing.
Not something that I've done there.
But yes, that was the question.
And yes, near-field
research you get a sense of
how children are impacted.
So the new ebb and flow
of the Mekong impacts
of space for kids or what kids can do
with their time in that space.
Yeah, the river is always a place that,
in the afternoon that kids play,
this is a place of recreation
as well as a place of work,
of activity too.
So, sure, a change of the river,
I'm not sure if so much of
that or other kinds of things.
Migrant labor is still a certain,
increasing in importance, as
fishing decreases in profit,
and migrant labor kind of
gets more and more important.
And so having a parent abroad,
is certainly an impact on
the lives of children there.
So in terms of the change in
the water, maybe not so much.
But the larger social change
that it changed in the river
(indistinct), definitely
has massive impacts
upon the lives of kids.
Definitely, sure.
- [Erik] Andrew, I wanna ask
you a question about time.
- Yeah.
- [Erik] And the thing that
I note about your book,
is that it operates at a very
almost metaphysical level.
I don't know if that's the
right word to use actually.
But it's in your talk here, in some sense,
you were more pragmatic than the book.
The book takes us into a
philosophical registers about
existence a little bit, right?
And so, I wanted to pose
a question about time
because you brought it
up in the talk here,
about the kind of meeting of
different time experiences,
not just time as watch time,
but a kind of cosmological time,
the time experience of the river,
and then how physical
transformation of the river
is actually transforming the experience
of time and temporality, right?
So you talked about space,
on one hand obviously
if you flood a river,
or you drain a river,
the shape, and look, and
form of it will be different,
and so it will change the
spatiality that people have to it,
right?
But the time was also so fascinating.
And what I wanted to ask you about,
was this idea of the Naga,
having a certain kind
of temporality, right?
But at the same time ...
sorry for the word at the same time.
But at the same time,
that people are reflecting on Naga time,
they're also very easily able to say,
"Well, there was the
Naga doing x, y, and z
and now there's not," right?
So there's a kind of
linearity of before and after,
that's pretty
straightforward on one level.
We used to do this, now
we don't do that anymore.
When the dam came,
everything changed, right?
And so my question to you,
is there really like a
kind of metaphysical,
or you could say ontological,
whatever word is appropriate
difference about time along the river?
Or is it really just a variation
of a kind of universal temporality?
And what are your thoughts on that?
And maybe we can't really
decide it right now.
But what are some of the
ways in which you thought
about that problem?
And just I'll add to it,
because even as we see
your friend in there,
I almost feel a visceral
difference of temporality,
because I remember my own
times along rivers, right?
When you're at a river,
you have a different
kind of engagement with
space time somehow, right?
And so how do we deal with that,
layered to the real time
of history, not real-time,
but that the temporality of history,
and then the temporality of an alternative
temporality along a river?
- I mean time is a perception, right?
So time depends upon your apprehension
of time and your experience of time,
and yeah, multiple different registers.
And I think one, I start off the book,
and talking about the
messianic and apocalyptic
time experiences.
So, when people talked about the dams,
a lot of times I start
off with a dream that
what one of my interlocutors
had, about the dam breaking,
and he dreamt that he
saw a gap in the dam,
and it was gonna one day crack in half,
and flood and destroy the entire town.
And so, that also that
places a particular marker
in the future of what happens
when these things fail,
or what happens when
they succeed too much,
what happens when we can no longer wait?
So there's this future
points, and then of course,
as you were saying there's
this sort of a past point too,
that like before the dam
came, it was like this.
And there's also, I think this feeds into,
there's a number of different registers
that this feeds into.
One is the cult of developments,
that is endemic many,
many places in the world,
maybe every place in the world.
But this idea that like that
things can continually progress
along a certain kind of
a linear path towards
more complexity, or more
developments, or we get ...
I remember the year
when we got electricity.
I remember the year when the,
where the road got paved.
I remember the year ...
These kinds of markers there.
And so that projects in the future,
kind of an upward trajectory,
that can then be cast
into doubt by intimations,
that, hey, there might
be disaster actually
at the end of this.
And so there are these points,
and various points in history,
and especially in Isan,
where you get this notion
of messianic time comes in.
There's a ...
What is it?
Millenarian group.
Not the millennials, there's something ...
There also apocalyptic but
there's something else.
But there's a movement in
the early two thousands,
or the early 19, fairly 20th century,
that was positing there would come a time
when everything would change its shape.
So, animals would become demons.
Money would become excrement.
And the only thing solid in
the world would be lemon grass.
Since he would've had
to hold onto the stalks
of lemon grass, don't
keep from being blown away
by a giant wind that would
sweep through the land.
Also, there was the communist movement,
which was tremendously
based in the province,
just very, very close to
this area in which people
in this village, and others
up and down in Mekong had
complicated relationships with.
So, and of course,
communism they also posited
a time free of imperialism,
a time of revolution,
the constant revolution.
So this constant deferment
of disaster and hope
often the future marks another point,
at which there's a future
point, there's a past point,
at which things were mythical, mystical,
when Naga was still alive.
And there you are caught somehow
between these two points,
and so you're waiting
for something to happen
in between these two, the
future point and the past point
you're caught.
And I think, yeah, there is a certain ...
About the actual, (indistinct)
It's a bit to talk about the time,
as that's the materiality of it,
the time that's embedded within
the material of the river.
That also has its own particular rhythms,
and its own particular cycles beyond
just the pulse of the Mekong.
But the way that time
passes in a particular day,
there's boats that come at night,
which are the fish shockers,
or maybe people running
meth from across the border
which happens.
Something untoward happening
in the middle of the night,
or maybe it's just your friends
coming back from illicit pub
in Laos really late.
Then the chanting starts
up around four or five
in the morning, and
then the animals start,
and then the traffic starts,
and the morning boats start,
and so there's a whole
auditory sensory perception
that informs you in a
very bodily way about
the passing of the time,
that is always connected to the river.
That's always linked to
that feeling of listening
to what the river is doing,
what people are doing on top of the river,
informs you of your sense of time,
of your sense of the passage of time.
So between like, yeah, the metaphysical,
the apocalyptic messianic
potentials in the future.
and then the kind of
experience of everyday
passage of time too.
I found time temporality and time,
and those debates (indistinct),
and these debates about,
we should really be saying
time and not temporality.
But this notion of the
affective passage of time
is something that I really ...
it's always very striking, I think.
- Thank you.
We have one question from Al.
Go ahead Al.
- Yeah, so kind of related to this,
something I took away from
the book was this idea
of ambivalence or productive
potential of maybe.
So you talk in the
opening (indistinct) about
how there's a sense of ambivalence.
And that, to me was really interesting.
Just taking seriously that ambivalence
with what we call a hunter
logical alternative,
so I thought that was super interesting.
But, I'm wondering how you reconcile that,
with a kind of anthropology
that's emerging
in terms of practices,
like people who want to go
with complicit, and like who
are the stakeholders at work,
and politics and accountability,
so how do you juggle with the kind of
ambivalence and accountability?
One is asking for kind
of like taking seriously
that murkiness.
But the other is murky,
but people wanna shine a light on it.
How do you position yourself
between these holes in a sense?
- That's a good question.
And that's also something
that I think about a lot.
And, I'd like to say I do both, right?
And that that's like the right answer.
But, so explain why I do both.
I mean, first off, I
have some very practical
and pragmatic alliances, that I think,
in the town where I work in that region,
there's a number of
NGOs that I meet up with
when I'm down there, and very practical.
Making sure that what I do,
doesn't damage the site
where I work, and in fact,
I'm able to help along the
interests of the people
with whom I work as much as I can.
On the other hand too,
I mean, I'm personally coming
from a very deconstructive
kind of anthropology, where
I think it's in reflexive.
I think it's always vital to
question your own assumptions
when you're coming into
a field work situation.
So questioning the
stakeholders, and saying,
"Okay, can we really chart out
the ethically right position,
the politically right position to take,
and then identify the
stakeholders involved.
I think Marisol Dilla Kadana
talks a little bit about this.
And incorporating non human stakeholders
within the thing, within your
plurry verse as she says,
within you're a political unit.
That's good.
I think that speaks towards
taking other ways of seeing
the world seriously,
but in addition to that,
I think we also need to recognize ...
And this is really important to me.
We need to see the other than human,
the non-human as our
interlocutors see it, or as ...
And not as like their
culture or their ontology
or something like that.
But we are all in a way questioning.
And myself included, questioning
what exists in the world.
And having real debates about
I remember having a talk
with another friend of mine
from the same region.
And friend of mine who we had been friends
since 2014 or something
like this, and he asked me,
"Do you believe in ghosts?"
And this is something that I get a lot,
I write a lot about ghosts,
and I'm very used to this question.
And so I answered, (speaking
on foreign language).
Which is the standard thing
you're supposed to say,
and he got angry with me.
And he said, "Look, I
asked you a question,
and I'm asking you sincerely."
And I realized that, I'd been
using that as a way of saying,
"Okay, so this is what I'm
interested in what you believe,
and your ideas, and now I'm
standing on my other side,
of my anthropologist side.
I'm gonna write this down, I'm gonna say,
okay, so this is Thai.
Metaphysical reality, ontological reality.
What are you gonna say?"
No, I wasn't being taken as that.
I was being taken as a
co-investigator in the world.
And so what he said is, he says,
"You've been around many places.
You studied a lot, you
must know something.
So, what do you know?
And let's compare."
And, I realized that he's
asking you to be taken seriously
as a co-investigator of a world.
And that, I think as an anthropologist
is very important for us to do that,
to recognize that our
interlocutors are collaborators
and not just in the sense of like,
Oh, we're gonna get together,
and maybe try to give photo
credit, or co-author something,
or co-present something.
But co-investigators into
the kinds of questions
we're asking.
Nobody has a distinct answer.
So who are the stakeholders?
Is the Naga stakeholder?
I don't know, nobody knows.
And I think answering that honestly
is one way of getting
true to the heart of what
the ethnography means to
destabilize your own sense
of shorty about what exists
and how the world works.
Which is what I think the
point of anthropology is.
So, let's stop there.
Co-researcher?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's ...
- Paul, before I let
you ask your question,
I wanted to just say one little thing.
I wrote that word co-researcher because
when you were speaking about
co-investigator, Andrew,
it reminded me of a misreading
that may be actually
interesting.
'Cause when I read your
book, you used the term,
and I think in the introduction somewhere,
I can't remember what page.
But the word co-researcher,
which I just wrote in
the chat for everyone.
But when I first read the word,
and this is honest truth,
I thought I'd never seen that
word written like that before,
and I thought that it meant core searcher.
- That's ...
Yeah.
- And the story that you're
telling, and then I said,
"Oh, actually he means co-researcher."
But then I remember pausing thinking,
well, actually what he's saying,
is that we're all in this together,
as searching for the core, right?
Which is sort of what the
story you just described
with your friend there.
He's like, "No, we're
not just co-investigator,
we're core searchers, and
we're doing it together,
looking for the core of human existence
or something like that, or something."
And so, I just wanted
to do that play on words
it was unintentional.
But I know that Paul has a question.
But you can respond to
that real quick if you want
- Paul and then I'll get some
Williams questions, yeah.
- I was curious, I had
the feeling that perhaps
these fishermen and
farmers on the Thai side,
must be complaining at
least to the regional
Thai government if not
the central government,
about what's happening.
What is the central government,
or the regional government say to them?
And I had the same question.
I don't know if you know what the Lao
fishermen and farmers are saying?
- My answer to that question
would have been different
two years ago.
And I think, it's a side anecdote.
There was one possession ritual,
sort of a spirit medium
ritual that I was involved in.
Where the people were
asking the spirit medium
to kind of stop the dams,
and get the spirits to stop the dams.
And the spirit calls up the
Laotian spirit on the phone,
and to ask, to request a stop to the dam.
And that what the Laotian spirit says is,
"This is what is necessary
for national developments."
And I think that would be the answer
that you would get from
the Lao government,
as well as the Lao spirit, the Lord too.
And I think, that's no accident
that the two were speaking
in the same voice.
On the Thai side, now
there's a lot of electricity.
In Bangkok, I'm sure many of
you have spent time there.
You have shopping malls
that consume as much,
individual shopping malls, that
consume as much electricity
as an entire province.
The province of (indistinct),
uses half as much electricity
as the shopping mall
of Siam Paragon.
So, Thailand has always been
a center-oriented state.
Where resources are pulled to the center.
They're part of the
pushback against the regime
of Thaksin Shinawatra
was a pushback against
the sort of distribution of wealth
a little bit outside of the center,
even though it was going
to his own projects.
But, the drawing in of
resources to the center,
has meant that the lives of
of people on the outskirts
don't get much play.
However, recently, this year even I think,
Thailand has formally complained
to the Lao government,
and has intimated that it
will not purchase electricity
from some of the new dams.
(indistinct) it's purchasing from.
But there are some of the new dams there,
that Thai government has
said it's not gonna to.
I don't know why, I don't
know what's behind that.
It may be good intentions.
It may be honorable intentions.
I don't trust it, but maybe.
But there is an act-
- [Paul] Is most-
- I'm sorry.
- Is most of the electricity being sold to
Thailand or to China?
- To Thai.
The electricity generated in
Laos, is going to Thailand.
Further upstream, some
of that may go to China.
But even the Chinese
names right on the border,
that's being sold for capital.
So William asks, speaking of co-research,
are you engaged in or
thinking of engaging in
multi-sided and extended project,
that incorporates other
anthropologists working
both up and downstream in
China, Cambodia, and Vietnam?
William, are you in charge of
a large grant making projects?
We could answer our own questions here.
Not yet, sad face.
Okay, well, let me know
when you are and we'll talk.
But I think practically speaking,
I would actually love to get involved
with our fishery scientists too.
Because the actual ...
There has not been a lot
of good fisheries studies
on the Mekong river.
Further down in Cambodia,
there have been some.
But the middle Mekong region,
and especially as you go
further up into Laos and China,
the barriers doing environmental
field work are increased.
Laos famously, some years ago,
environmental activists
disappeared, and presumably ...
Make it interdisciplinary
and add a geographer.
Sure, yes.
Now let's find grants everyone.
- I think you've seen with
our modest evening right here
we've created a Mekong studies coalition.
I mean, so I hope all
of you can be in touch
with each other.
But it's quite clear that
the work is important.
I wanna bring it to a close right now,
with our evening discussions.
I try not to go too late just to make sure
that we all don't get exhausted.
But if anyone has a final question
they're really dying to ask,
we can do that right now.
Otherwise, we'll turn off the recorder
and bring the session to a close.
So, let me just see if
there's any further questions.
And I do hope that folks will, sorry,
tune to some of the
upcoming events webinar
Southeast Asia Council Brown Bag series,
and in our side Eddy
series on waters here.
I will draw your attention
in particular to our
talk in the Brown Bag.
Next week, we'll be Vince Raphael,
who will be giving a a very
provocatively titled talk
called Duterte phallus.
I don't have the full subtitle.
But it's the aesthetics of
vulgarity in Duterte Philippines.
So I think it will be
quite a great experience,
and I hope some of you
can join us for that.
Those talks are on Wednesdays at noon.
And then there's a few other
series, in the water series.
And then at the end of
the academic semester,
there's the big graduate
student conference.
And, so I hope we can all tune into some
of these other events.
Thanks everyone.